Genau, das wird aufgezeigt.
Alles gut.
Ja, wir können anfangen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich heise Dr.
Adybaydin.
Ich bin heute eher zuständiger Arzt.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen das an einem Gespräch führen.
So erst brauche ich Ihre persönlichen Daten.
Dann kommen wir so in Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, gebe mir bitte Bescheid.
Okay, sind Sie damit verstanden?
Ja, okay.
Wie heisen Sie?
Ich heisse Peter Lindemann.
Peter Lindemann.
Könnten Sie Ihre Vornahme und Nachnahme langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, Peter schreibt sich P-E-T-E-R.
Peter und Lindemann, der Nachname L-I-N-D-E-M-A-N-N.
Lindemann.
Ja, Herr Lindemann.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
60 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12. April 1965.
1965.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,84 m groß.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
93 kg.
Vielen Dank.
Wie heisst Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausarztin?
Das ist Frau Dr. Lang.
L-A-N-G.
Lang.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Herr Lindemann.
Wie kann ich Ihnen heute helfen?
Seit zwei Tagen fühle ich mich sehr müde.
Ja.
Ich habe Muskelschmerzen und Gelenkschmerzen.
Ich habe auch Husten und ich habe Fieber.
Okay.
Welche Beschwerden schrecklich für Sie?
Welche besonders schlimm sind?
Ja.
Allgemein.
Ich bin kaputt.
Ich bin müde.
Ich friere.
Ich habe Schüttelfrost.
Und der Husten.
Es ist alles.
Okay.
Sind Ihre Husten in der Nähe?
Ja.
Sind Ihre Husten mit Würfen oder Tognen?
Mit Auswurf.
Ja.
Also da kommt so gelblicher, etwas bräunlicher Schleim raus.
Gelblicher und schleimlicher, okay.
Und bräunlicher.
Okay.
Haben Sie im Auswurf Blutstöße
gesehen?
Blut habe ich nicht direkt gesehen.
Okay.
Ja.
Haben Sie Ihre Fieber gemessen?
Ja, im Mund.
Im Mund?
Wie viel Geld?
39.
Okay, so schrecklich.
Haben Sie dagegen ein Medikament eingeladen?
Nein.
Ich habe erst vor 2 Stunden gemessen.
Als das Fieber so hoch war und es mir so schlecht geht,
hat meine Frau gesagt,
jetzt müssen wir zu Ihnen in das Krankenhaus, in die Ambulanz.
Ja, richtig.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung gemacht.
Und Muskel schwach haben.
Haben Sie müde auch?
Sind Ihnen...
Wie sind Ihre Appetit?
Seit 2 Tagen nicht gut.
Sonst ist der Appetit gut,
aber seit 2 Tagen, seitdem es mir so schlecht geht,
habe ich mich nicht mehr geholfen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Also etwas, aber beim Husten eben.
Ich muss häufig husten und etwas Atemnot habe ich.
Ich habe auch Schmerzen beim Atmen,
hinter dem Schulterblatt, im Rücken,
auf der rechten Seite,
habe ich da auch Schmerzen, wenn ich einatme.
Okay.
Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10,
keine Schmerzen,
sehr stark Schmerzen.
5.
Okay.
Diese Beschwerden, Ihre Schmerzen,
plötzlich sind Ihre Schmerzen plötzlich
oder langsam aufgetreten?
Langsam.
Langsam. Ihre Schmerzen rechtsseitige oder linksseitige?
Rechts.
Rechtshinten, unter dem Schulterblatt.
Ja.
Haben Sie Hass- oder Naken-Schmerzen?
Nein.
Strahlen Ihre Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Okay.
Ist Ihnen eine Beusseinlosigkeit oder
ohnmächtig bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schluckbeschwerden?
Nein.
Haben Sie Beschwerden beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Stuhlgang ist in Ordnung, regelmäßig Wasserlassen.
Ich muss ein bis zweimal in der Nacht auf Toilette.
Das auch schon seit einigen Jahren.
Das stört mich aber nicht.
Da habe ich auch keine Beschwerden.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Nein, bis auf die letzten zwei Dächte.
Sonst habe ich keine Schlafprobleme.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Haben Sie Hautveränderung?
Nein.
Haben Sie keine Bemerkungen?
Haben Sie noch etwas anderer Beschwerden?
Nein.
Alles dieses? Okay.
Ich möchte zusammenfassen wiederholen.
Haben Sie Müdigkeit, Muskelschmerzen, Hüsten mit Auswürfe,
gerbisch, schlammlich und bräulich?
Nein.
Haben Sie 39 Grad Fieber, Schulterfrost
und bei Wüsten haben Sie Atemnotprobleme?
Ja, seit zweitag.
Alles seit zweitag.
Haben es für Ihre Beschwerden ein Auslöser?
Nein, habe ich keine Erklärung für.
Was liebt oder verstärkt Ihre Schmerzen?
Ich darf mich nicht belasten, weil ich stärkeren Hüsten habe.
Ich bin so schlapp und müde, ich muss ruhig liegen bleiben.
Okay.
Ich bin ruhig, besser geht.
Ja, habe Sie keine Erklärung.
Leiden Sie an eine chronische Erkrankung?
Ja, ich habe erhöhte Cholesterinwerte, seit fünf Jahren.
Okay.
Ich habe auch erhöhte Harnsäurewerte, seit drei Jahren.
Da habe ich auch zweimal bereits einen Gichtanfall gehabt.
Also sei es ein Gichtanfall am Großen Zee.
Und dann habe ich in den letzten Jahren auch mindestens zweimal im Jahr
eine schwere Bronchitis, sondern im Winter, im Herbst.
Und auch oft mit Fieber und da muss ich auch Antibiotika nehmen.
Okay.
Aber jetzt ist das anders.
Jetzt sind die Beschwerden anders als bei so einer Bronchitis.
Ja, ich habe wegen Geräusche nicht alles gehört.
Also haben Sie Fettshoffblutfett-Werthöl?
Ja, Cholesterin.
Okay, Cholesterin.
Und Harnsäuregiftprobleme haben Sie seit drei Jahren?
Ja, seit ungefähr drei Jahren ist die Harnsäure erhöht.
Und ich hatte schon zweimal jetzt einen Gichtanfall.
Ja, okay.
Und haben etwas diese seit Bronchitis gelebt, oder?
Ja, in den letzten Jahren schon.
Zwei Mal im Jahr habe ich dann oft eine schwere Bronchitis.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie noch etwas anderes?
Nein.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert?
Operiert worden, ja.
Als Kind, da war ich zehn Jahre alt.
Da bin ich an den Manteln operiert worden.
Okay.
Und im Alter von zwölf Jahren bin ich am Leistenbruch operiert worden,
auf der linken Seite.
Okay.
Und im Alter von 30 Jahren hatte ich beim Fußballspielen
einen Bruch am Sprunggelenk.
Und das musste auch operiert werden.
Und dann sind bei mir seit einigen Jahren Gallensteine bekannt.
Gallensteine?
Ja, seit einigen Jahren.
Aber die werden immer mal wieder mit Ultraschall angeguckt,
aber bisher wird nichts unternommen.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Medikaments Regelmasik ein?
Ja, ich nehme einmal Medikament ein gegen Cholesterin.
Ja, okay.
Das Medikament heißt Simvastatin.
Ja.
Wie viel Medikament?
Dahinter steht 20.
Und dann nehme ich eine Tablette abends.
Okay.
Und dann nehme ich noch Alu Purinol.
Purinol, ja, gegen Geeth.
Ja, 300 steht dahinter, 300.
Dann nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Ja.
Sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente.
Okay, bei Bedarf nehmen Sie?
Nein, bei Bedarf nicht.
Nur wenn ich, wie gesagt, Bronchitis habe,
dann bekomme ich ein Antibiotikum.
Ja, wie verstehen Sie?
Sind Sie gegen Kinderkernkeit geimpft?
Ja, da achtet meine Hausärztin drauf,
dass ich die notwendigen Impfungen bekomme.
Ja, perfekt.
Covid und Influenza, ich glaube.
Ja, und auch gegen Lumen, Entzündung und alles Mögliche.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen eine Allergie oder Unfährtsfähigkeit bekannt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche eine Schachtel pro Tag.
Eine Schachtel pro Tag?
Das ist ungefähr seit 35 Jahren.
35 Jahre.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich trinke mal ein Bier, aber ich muss aufpassen,
weil ich bin vom Beruf Taxifahrer.
Ja.
Und da ist das mit Alkoholtrinken ein besonderes Schwierigkeit.
Also ich trinke eher wenig Alkohol.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie, aber Alkohol trinken
oder Zigaretten rauchen für Ihre Gesund nicht gut.
Ich empfehle Sie immer für Ihre Gesundheit,
erst mal Ihre Rauchen aufhören.
Ja, das ist gut.
Erst mal reduzieren und dann aufhören.
Es ist eine Möglichkeit, wenn Sie aufhören möchten,
es gibt eine gute Lösung für Sie.
Ich kenne eine Sozialdienst.
Nach dem Gespräch können wir noch mal sprechen.
Okay, gut.
Erst mal möchte ich gerne, dass Sie mir helfen,
dass das Fieber weggeht und dass es mir besser geht.
Ja, Sie, richtig.
Okay.
Bitte denken Sie nicht persönlich.
Ich frage alle meine Patienten.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Nein, nicht mehr.
Okay.
Sind Sie Taxifahren?
Haben Sie gesagt?
Ja.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Wir haben zwei Kinder, die sind 30 und 32 Jahre alt.
Die wohnen aber nicht mehr bei uns, aber sie sind gesund.
Sind Sie wochenamt mit Ihrer EV?
Ja.
Okay.
Herr Lindemann, lebt Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter lebt noch, die ist 82 Jahre alt.
Sie hat hohen Blutdruck.
Sie hat Alterszucker.
Okay.
Und mein Vater, der lebt nicht mehr.
Der ist an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Da war er 80 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Herr Lindemann, ich habe alle Fragen gefragt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinversügen?
Ja, was kann das sein?
Ja, Sie haben erst mal eine Bronchitis, auch Pneumonie.
Typisch, ich weiss nicht, aber wir brauchen ein paar Untersuchungen.
Dann Blut entnommen, dann Apparativdiagnose machen.
Bis danach, ich informiere mich über Ihre Diagnosis.
Aber erst mal Sie hier bleiben, ich empfehle Sie stationäre Aufnahmen,
weil Sie ein hoher Fieber und braunlicher Ausfüff,
erst mal wie eine richtige Plan machen.
Okay, gut.
Dann haben Sie etwas Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Übersetzen Sie bitte die Patientensprache in medizinischer Fachbegriffe.
Ja, richtig.
Wenn Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch Fragen haben,
sollen Sie sie bitte jetzt stellen.
Ja, danke.
Die wesentlichen Fragen sind gestellt worden.
Es gibt schwierige Patienten, ich glaube.
Ich hätte die Fragen noch gestellt,
im Rahmen der Familienanamnese nach Geschwistern.
Ja, richtig.
Sie haben nicht gefragt.
Es gibt eine Schwester, die ist 57 Jahre alt.
Sie hatte vor zwei Jahren Brustkrebs, ist operiert worden.
Es tut mir leid.
Und es gibt einen Bruder, der ist 55 Jahre alt.
Der hat hohen Blutdruck.
Okay, ich teile dir die Bett-Aktion auch.
Gut, das sind, denke ich, die wesentlichen Fragen,
die man stellen sollte.
Das Gewicht sollte doch gefragt werden.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Der Patient hat sein Gewicht gehalten.
Er hat weder zugenommen noch abgenommen in den letzten Wochen oder Monaten.
Das ist also unauffällig.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ihr habt nicht gefragt, aber vielen Dank.
Lasst Sie jetzt mal ein, zwei Minuten noch alleine,
dann können Sie sich besser konzentrieren.
Dann komme ich gleich wieder zurück.
Ich habe einen Patient.
Ich möchte Ihnen den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, habe ich.
Vielen Dank.
Der 60-jährige Patient heißt Peter Lindermann.
Er ist April 2. 1985 geboren.
April 12.
Der Patient stellte sich heute seit vor zwei Tagen akut bestehender,
mit Prudulant auswürfen.
Mit Tussis und Auswurf oder Expektorans vor?
Mit Sputum.
Wie sieht der Sputum aus?
Der Patient klagt über Schultafrost, Fratik, Muskelschmerzen.
Ja, Muskelschmerzen.
Schultafrost, auch Schultafrost.
Schultafrost, Schultafrost, Schultafrost, Schultafrost.
Er klagt über Myalgie, Artralgie, Artralgie,
febrile Temperaturen von 39 Grad, Oral gemessen.
Der Auswurf wird als gelblich bräunlich beschrieben.
Der Patient klagt über inspiratorische Schmerzen,
Rechtsdorsal im Bereich der Skapular.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Unterstützung.
Ich frage mich, dass der Patient seit fünf Jahren das Hypercholestronomie gibt.
Das ist Hyperurikemi.
Er ist seit drei Jahren mit 2-mal gelbter Gittattage.
Er ist durch Artritis urika.
Hat der Patient sonst noch chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, es gibt auch 2-mal letzte Jahr Bronschitis Leid an.
Ihre Veroperationen sind mit 10 Jahren eine Transylaktomie,
mit 12 Jahren in Grünal-Herrni, linken, seitiger, in Grünal-Herrni-Operationen
und mit 30 Jahren Sprunggelenk, linken Sprunggelenk,
wegen Sprunggelenkbruch für eine Operatur,
mit Sprunggelenkfraktur, Maläolusfraktur,
hat der Patient sonst noch etwas?
Ja, wegen einer Gallenstein-Prospektation
hat er stationell aufnahmengebliebt.
Hat der Patient bekannte Gallensteine, die nicht operiert wurden?
Ja, nicht operiert wurden, aber ein bisschen recherchiert,
aber nicht richtige Kolelithiasisdiagnose festgestellt.
Aber ein paar Untersuchungen gelten.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familienanamnese?
Ja, in der Familie Mutter, ihre Mutter, seine Mutter,
leider an arterielle Hypertonie,
und Diabetes Melitus, Typ 1, Typ 2, Alterzucker.
Alter ist Zucker, Alter ist Zucker,
und ein Zucker, der erst im hohen Alter, mit 60 Jahren, um 60 Jahren.
Ich habe eigentlich Alterzucker, Typ 2,
und seine Vater leider an Lungenkarcinom verstorben.
Der Vater ist von 80 Jahren verstorben.
Hat das Geschwister? Ja, und seine Bruder ist 57 Jahre,
wegen Brustkarcinom auch verstorben.
Die Schwester hat vor zwei Jahren einen Brustkarcinom,
und seine Bruder ist leider an Arterielle Hypertension.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Die anamnestätische Angaben wie Tussis, Fibar,
Mealgie, Fatigue und Prolan mit gelbliher, schleimliher, brumliher Ausfüff mit Tussis
und am besten auf Pynomonie hin.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen atypische Pynomonien,
und Bronschialkarcinom auch begleitet und wegen der Schmerzen,
und die Skapulla-Schmerzen, Lungenembole auch denken wie.
Die Verdacht auf eine Brontiopneumonie,
hat eine Begleitploretis, deswegen inspiratorische Schmerz.
Die andere Dinge kann auch eine Fieberhafte Brontitis sein.
Sie haben eine COPD der Patientin,
Sie müssen noch etwas sagen,
Sie können sagen es besteht ein erheblicher Nikotin-Abosus von 35 Packages.
Vielen Dank.
Die wesentlichen Fachbegriffe haben Sie gut übersetzt,
Sie haben eine einfache Sätze zu formulieren,
nicht zu lange, das ist meine Philosophie.
Wenn der Patient fragt,
seien Sie vorsichtig mit Diagnosen,
ich möchte Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen,
ich würde sagen,
wir müssen das jetzt step by step haben.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche,
wünsche Ihnen allen einen schönen Abend.
Tschüss.